Quand j'étais au CM1, j'avais mis au point un code
secret absolument génial pour communiquer.
L'idée c'était que dans un message,
vous remplacez chaque lettre
par la lettre qui la suit dans l'alphabet.
Voilà, c'est tout.
Eh bien, aujourd'hui on va voir comment on
peut faire beaucoup beaucoup mieux que ça.
Evidemment l'idée de coder un message
en remplaçant chaque lettre
par la suivante n'est pas de moi,
elle est vieille comme le monde,
on appelle ça le chiffrement par décalage.
Il paraît que César l'utilisait pour
communiquer avec ses généraux et
d'ailleurs certains appellent ça le code de César.
Sauf que César avait été un tout
petit peu plus malin que moi puisque
il pouvait utiliser des décalages qui
n'étaient pas forcément d'une lettre
mais qui pouvait être de 3 lettres, 7 lettres ou 12 lettres.
Si César voulait envoyer un message,
il choisissait un décalage
et il suffisait que son destinataire
connaisse la valeur du décalage
pour reconstituer le message de départ.
Bien sûr un code comme celui de César
n'est pas très difficile à casser,
une fois que vous connaissez le principe.
Si jamais demain vous interceptez
un message de César,
il suffit d'essayer tous les décalages possibles,
et il n'y en a que 25,
jusqu'à trouver celui qui fonctionne
donc ce n'est pas un code très très solide.
Si vous voulez quelque chose de plus robuste,
vous pouvez par exemple utiliser
une méthode légèrement différente
où vous remplacez chaque lettre par
une autre lettre de l'alphabet,
mais pas forcément issue d'un décalage,
c'est ce qu'on appelle le chiffrement par substitution.
Si vous prenez un message qui a
été codé par substitution
et que vous essayez de le décoder
en testant tous les codes possibles,
eh bien il y a beaucoup plus de
possibilités.
On peut faire rapidement le calcul,
pour coder la lettre A, il y a 26 possibilités
pour la lettre B, il en reste 25 pour la
lettre C, 24, etc...
Donc le nombre total de codes
par substitution possibles
c'est ce qu'on appelle factorielle de 26.
C'est un nombre absolument énorme et
juste pour vous donner un ordre d'idée,
si vous étiez capable d'essayer un
million de codes à chaque seconde,
il vous faudrait quand même 13 000 milliards
d'années pour les essayer tous,
c'est-à-dire mille fois l'âge de l'univers.
Donc avec des chiffres comme ça on a
envie de penser que les codes
par substitution sont absolument impossible à casser,
et en fait ce n'est pas vrai, ils sont
même assez faciles à craquer.
Pour comprendre comment on peut casser facilement
les textes qui sont codés par substitution,
on peut prendre un exemple donc là
je vous mets un message que j'ai codé
avec un certain code par substitution
et il y a une chose que vous pouvez
observer sur ce message,
c'est qu'il y a une lettre qui revient assez souvent
et d'ailleurs assez souvent en fin de mot
c'est la lettre T.
Donc on a de bonnes raisons de penser
que la lettre T doit certainement symboliser le E
Ce principe-là on peut le pousser beaucoup plus loin
et faire ce qu'on appelle de l'analyse des fréquences.
Vous regardez la fréquence d'apparition
des différentes lettres dans le message
et vous la comparez à la fréquence
d'apparition des lettres en français.
Donc ça c'est quelque chose de bien connu, on sait que
la lettre la plus fréquente c'est le E, ensuite c'est le A etc.
Donc si vous connaissez la langue
d'origine du message et que ce message
est suffisamment long pour se prêter à
ce genre d'analyse statistique,
on peut assez rapidement grandement
réduire le nombre de possibilités à tester.
Il existe même des algorithmes
qui peuvent à eux tout seuls
quasiment casser un code par substitution.
Alors voyez que la faiblesse du code
par substitution et qui fait qu'on peut
l'attaquer par analyse de fréquence,
c'est le fait qu'une lettre donnée par exemple le E,
va être toujours représentée par la
même lettre dans le message codé.
Il existe des moyens d'éviter ça et on peut utiliser
par exemple une clé de chiffrement.
Donc le principe est le suivant,
il vous faut choisir un mot clé,
alors par exemple on va prendre le mot science,
vous écrivez votre message et sous
votre message vous écrivez
votre mot-clé autant de fois que nécessaire.
Ensuite pour coder le message, vous
ajoutez chaque lettre du message
à la lettre du mot clé qui lui correspond.
Quand je dis vous ajoutez les lettres,
évidemment ce que vous faites,
c'est que vous ajoutez leur position dans l'alphabet
et puis si jamais ça dépasse 26 vous revenez à 0.
En faisant ça vous obtenez un message codé et
vous pouvez observer que dans ce message codé
une lettre donnée par exemple le E, n'est
par toujours représentée par la même lettre
et donc grâce à ce procédé vous pouvez échapper
à l'attaque par analyse de fréquences
Alors pour que ça marche bien il faut
prendre une clé suffisamment longue
là, j'ai juste pris un mot, mais
vous pouvez très bien prendre
une phrase voir carrément un paragraphe en entier.
Donc dans ces conditions ce genre de code
peut devenir quasiment inviolable.
Alors il y a juste un petit problème avec ce type de code,
c'est que vous devez donner la clé à quelqu'un
pour qu'il vous envoie des messages codés.
Imaginons que vous soyez une agence de services secrets et que vous ayez des espions sur le terrain.
Vous avez envie que ces espions
vous envoient des messages codés,
mais il y a un petit risque, c'est que
si jamais ils se font piquer la clé
ou que la clé se fait intercepter au moment
où vous la transmettez,
du coup l'ennemi peut décoder vos messages.
La raison c'est que ce type de code est
ce qu'on appelle un code symétrique,
c'est-à-dire que la clé pour coder les messages
et la clé pour les décoder, c'est la même.
Mais en fait ce n'est pas du tout obligatoire.
Dans les années 70 au MIT à Boston
trois chercheurs en informatique
ont mis au point un système de cryptographie
qu'on appelle asymétrique
c'est-à-dire que la clé pour coder et la clé
pour décoder ne sont pas les mêmes.
C'est ce qu'on appelle l'algorithme RSA
du nom des trois inventeurs.
Alors l'algorithme RSA je ne vais pas vous le décrire ici,
il n'est pas extrêmement compliqué,
il y a juste un peu de maths, mais je vous
mettrai un lien dans la description.
Ce qui est intéressant de comprendre
c'est comment ça fonctionne.
Pour faire un codage selon l'algorithme
RSA il faut que vous choisissiez une clé,
et une clé c'est un nombre, alors on
va prendre par exemple le nombre 143.
donc il y a toute une procédure et à partir
de cette clé vous fabriquez votre message codé.
Le truc c'est que pour décoder le
message,
il faut que la personne possède la décomposition
de ce nombre en facteurs premiers,
donc dans le cas de 143 c'est par exemple 11 fois 13.
Donc la clé de codage c'est 143
mais la clé de décodage c'est 11 et 13.
Alors dans ce cas-là ce n'est pas hyper compliqué
de retrouver la clé de décodage
une fois qu'on connait la clé
de codage que si je vous dis 143,
vous pouvez très bien trouver que c'est 11 fois 13,
mais si je m'amuse à prendre
un nombre beaucoup plus gros,
là, ça devient quasiment impossible de retrouver
sa décomposition en facteurs premiers.
Donc en pratique, si vous voulez utiliser
l'algorithme RSA, qu'est-ce que vous faites?
Vous prenez deux nombres premiers énormes,
vous les multipliez entre eux et ça
vous fabrique votre clé de codage.
Cette clé là vous pouvez la distribuer
à peu près à n'importe qui,
d'ailleurs parfois on appelle ça la clé publique.
Par contre les deux nombres premiers de
départ vous les gardez pour vous,
c'est la clé de décodage, c'est ce
qu'on appelle la clé privée.
Donc grâce à ça, des gens partout peuvent vous
envoyer des messages qu'ils vont pouvoir coder
mais ce n'est pas pour autant qu'ils pourront
décoder les messages des autres
et donc même si la clé fuite et que
l'ennemi arrive à s'en emparer,
il n'y a aucun problème,
ils ne pourront pas décoder vos messages.
L'algorithme RSA aujourd'hui,
on le trouve un petit peu partout
et il est même à la base d'un grand nombre de
protocoles de communication sécurisés sur internet.
Donc il y a une grande partie de la
sécurité informatique mondiale
et donc probablement de la stabilité de l'économie
qui repose sur des cryptages de ce type
et c'est quand même marrant que tout
ça tient, in fine, au fait que
mathématiquement, c'est compliqué de
trouver les facteurs premiers d'un nombre.
D'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'à une certaine
époque, il y en a qui s'inquiétaient
de l'arrivée possible des ordinateurs
quantiques, parce que l'une des choses
qu'un ordinateur quantique est censé
faire beaucoup mieux qu'un ordinateur classique,
c'est factoriser des nombres.
Donc si demain quelqu'un se pointait avec
un ordinateur quantique suffisamment puissant,
il pourrait casser toutes les clés RSA et donc
ça foutrait probablement un beau bordel.
Heureusement à ce jour,
je crois que le plus gros nombre qu'un ordinateur
quantique ait réussi à factoriser c'est 143,
donc 11 fois 13.
Vous voyez qu'on a encore un petit
peu de tranquillité devant nous.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo, n'hésitez pas à la
partager surtout pour m'aider à faire connaître la chaîne.
Vous pouvez vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait,
aller voir mes vidéos précédentes
et me retrouver sur Facebook, sur Twitter et aussi
sur mon blog qui s'appelle "Science Étonnante".
A bientôt !